many people forced to stay home because
of the coronavirus are finding new
hobbies some are gardening many are
baking bread and our CBS Sunday morning
correspondent Lee Cowan has caught up
with some of these people showing us how
they are discovering new passions as our
streets emptied our homes filled up and
in our often cramped existence
something has happened from sidewalk art
to surrealism
kovat 19 is tapped a creative nerve that
many of us never even knew we had it
might be dance it might be baking it
might be designing a garden it doesn't
matter it's not the end product it's the
process absolutely the process if you
start something beautiful will happen
this is wild Aulani Lardner is a former
journalist turned creativity consultant
before the outbreak she was helping
business executives self explore through
art you need two things a desire and
time and a global pandemic just gave you
the time it's not just about filling the
time now like learning to play ping pong
by yourself or taking up knitting though
must have found something that feeds
their soul for st. louis designer and
photographer trying to Travis it was
soil where she found solace there is a
certain joy in just getting your hands
dirty oh and I've got the nails to prove
it
she spent the shutdown creating life
where there wasn't a garden side-by-side
with her son one time with my son and oh
look I'm getting emotional he's really
been wonderful for me to have this time
with him has been priceless honestly so
while she and her son went out on a
gardening limb together
in you a and her husband Joseph got
their hands dirty a different way they
learned to bake together in their New
York kitchen but now you have no time to
enjoy each other's company and really
really do things that Wow
requires you know collaboration requires
time requires working together is just a
fun thing to do what's been the best
thing you've made you think the rustic
apple pie
the rustic is the key part of it so it
means you can look a little rustic she's
a dancer by trade baking is sort of a
dance to as long as you have the
ingredients to choreograph it flour it
we went to like store after store
there's no flour that's because everyone
is probably doing what you're doing
obviously people are baking and crazy
some of those lucky enough to have
enough flour and yeast are now just
showing off like this pizza crust turned
flower garden the point though is
whether it's baking or gardening or
painting you don't have to be good at it
for it to ease your anxiety happy
accidents are the best thing that can
happen we can only hope those creative
accidents will be more lasting than the
virus itself things that are not planned
and they just happen because you're
there and you're doing it oh that's
nirvana that's where you want to be
especially now yeah especially now
to CBS this morning I'm weekend in Los
Angeles so I love everything about that
story but Gail I do want to say a word
for the idlers out there doing nothing
and going nowhere is something I'm
practicing every day and there could be
a passion in that as well
no Tony I've been meaning to tell you
all week I've been reading articles
about you and Kate eater from MSNBC how
you're navigating working together in
the basement you guys seem to be
becoming very creative down there I
think it's great I think it's great
something for us all to learn